europa autorizar a las primeras vacunas
contra el hobbit 19 la próxima semana
expertos de la agencia europea de
medicamentos evaluarán la vacuna
fabricada por facer y bayón tech el 21
de diciembre para acelerar el inicio de
la campaña la comisión europea pidió a
los miembros del bloque comenzar la
vacunación en simultáneo
empecemos con la vacunación tan pronto
como sea posible juntos los 27 estados
en junin empezaremos el mismo día como
hemos ido en unidad a lo largo de esta
pandemia empecemos la erradicación de
este horrible y dos juntos y unidos
united las naciones europeas no están
obligadas a lanzar sus campañas de
vacunación al mismo tiempo pero alemania
francia italia y otros cinco estados
anunciaron su intención de coordinar
esfuerzos en francia el gobierno
confirmó que las primeras vacunas se
aplicarán a adultos mayores que viven en
residencias una acción que espera
ejecutar antes de fin de año se pone a
fas con un avión
emilio de peso la fase 1 alcanzará a un
millón de personas esta campaña iniciará
en los próximos días tan pronto como
tengamos la aprobada
necesaria de la agencia europea de
medicamentos para sacar la vacuna al
mercado se espera que eso ocurra el 21
de diciembre o bien yo y médica no dieta
toniu dieta tan duro frente a anderson 8
por su parte alemania anunció que
iniciará la vacunación el 27 de
diciembre en hogares de ancianos tras la
aprobación y la distribución de la
vacuna de facer bayón tec con 300
millones de dosis de esa inmunización la
unión europea podría vacunar al 33 por
ciento de sus habitantes